all right nick
nick where'd you grow up where are you
from originally originally from
wisconsin i was born in madison
i went to school there a few years then
i moved to waunakee wisconsin graduated
high school there went to stevens point
college for a year wrestled and then ran
out of money and joined the air force
you're right
and what's your childhood like
well you don't know better when you're a
child you don't know what's going on
uh so
you try to make the the best of every
moment as as people do
but when you're
you can be
you can be a victim and not know it not
know what's what's really happening and
i've
done much dissecting of my childhood and
what's happened since then and
once again you know at the time i didn't
know i didn't
i didn't understand the the problems of
two kids when they're 20 having a child
and what usually happens from that
and it's rarely
rarely that child develops to be a
confident and capable individual
very recently and many studies will
indicate that they do
fall
fall off the fall off the track
and take bad paths when it comes to
drugs
other addictions you know depression and
not being confident more than anything
if when when kids have kids it's rare
that
they're confident much less they know
how to be confident much less they know
how to teach confidence much less they
know how to teach a child confidence
so little to say i had my my struggles
i thought
i thought i was broken
i thought i needed medication
i was good at lying and faking my way
through everything though so very few
people knew of my struggles
in
in fourth grade i faked a heart attack
to get out of answering a question in
front of the class
i fell to the ground and pretended i was
having a heart attack went to the
nurse's office and i kind of remember
the awkward phone call when they called
my mom to tell her that i was saying i
had a heart attack
i remember feeling that nobody believed
me but they had no idea what was going
on
and that's that continued for for many
years couldn't talk to girls
it was hard to make friends
and i had to wear special shirts in high
school that didn't show my my sweat
i remember i wore a gray shirt one time
and
i'd sweat from
elbow all the way down here and i had to
keep my arms down and
i was just in a constant state of panic
i had panic attacks in front of my
extended family at the dinner table as
well i'm i'm curious of how i
not only survived but prevailed but
i do come to believe that those who
suffered the most can be the
the greatest warriors
absolutely
and since
you finished with school and all that
you you wanted what kind of work
well i joined the air force for the gi
bill to finish up my my school my mom
and dad gave me a little bit of money
but they didn't have much
for the first year of college i think i
took out loans anyway
and
i joined the air force for the gi bill
so i used that i actually transferred in
a job that allowed me to take full-time
credits
luckily i found the the drive or
motivation or guidance somewhere to uh
to know the importance of getting some
sort of degree and i chose english and
english bachelor degree which i'm
grateful for i think everybody should i
think i think it's the best degree out
there to start schooling with it helps
with analyzing creativity
which are very important obviously
reading and writing as well
so you asked the job after the air force
yeah i just wonder what you did when you
were kind of finished with your
schooling when i okay well
so i did four years in the air force and
i went to school full time i got most of
my school knocked out when i left the
air force i had the the biggest
crossroads of my life i had about a year
left of school
and it was either go back to wisconsin
and start a
grass and snow removal
business grass cutting a snow removal
business or go to california and pursue
dreams of entertainment
and uh
developing my confidence and becoming
something who i really wanted to be
and
i bought a large trailer and i it came
down to the last week when i was getting
out i was either gonna i was gonna pack
up all my stuff on that trailer and i
bought a trailer for lawn mowing it was
one that you could drive a lawnmower on
and everything
but i i needed it regardless to pack all
my stuff on and go one of the places
and i did chose i do i did choose
california
i drove down beach boulevard
um in huntington beach i got out i got a
paper and i looked for somewhere to live
and work
uh never being there i didn't know one
person who lived in california i knew
nothing about traffic i wanted to i want
to live in the beach cities in orange
county
and commute to hollywood
and i did that for about a year
and i got my first gig on tyra banks i
was a security guard for the america's
next models america's top models
whatever that was
and i drove like three hours in traffic
there and like four on the way back and
i'm like okay i gotta move there
but
uh what i did for work there
um
waited tables
i waited tables
okay before i joined the air force i
i don't know what is that
yeah in between my year of college and
before i joined the air force i actually
took a year off where i got in a lot of
trouble i actually
i sold drugs hustled pool did a bunch of
bad stuff and i waited tables and
bartended
at places so i had experience doing that
so when i moved to california i did get
a job serving tables at mccormick and
schmix actually in irvine
and shortly after that is when i got the
balls to
call a company and tell them i wanted to
be a stripper
when i was 16 there was somebody in the
town who was 17 who did that and i
remember he could buy
he could buy beer and blow and he had a
truck and he moved out his senior year
and got his own place he had a guitar
and
i just i not only envied that you know
he could support himself by doing this
but i envied
the courage that it would take to get
down to a g string and strip in front of
girls i couldn't talk to girls
and and i'm like i got it i i got to do
this i got i got to figure this out like
i saw it as a puzzle a calculation that
i had to solve
and
i got the balls and i called this
company in california and i told my
experience i figured i'd have to lie to
to get in the door
and they're like come out this friday we
have a show going on
and i went to the show
and i met the the owner and the main guy
who was the cop act
who is the cockiest most arrogant person
you'll ever meet he's fighting with the
owner they're getting into it girls are
just screaming i'm throwing money at him
and everything though he's everything i
wanted to be at the time
and
the owner called me up a few days later
i said so and so got fired you're in
next week friday like the cop act
so that's how i got my big start
i don't remember the beginning too much
i found alcohol that helped me get on
stage and help me with the girls i'd get
sloppy drunk though like i don't
remember any of it
my
my first bachelorette party ever did i
remember i did a
i was with the boss so i remember i
didn't get too sloppy drunk
and
i did a lap dance for 30 seconds
and then
i remember thinking to myself what am i
going to do for the next 59 minutes and
30 seconds
and i blacked out
i don't remember anything i
remember
walking i remember up to that point and
then not even leaving through the door
but like
it kicked back in when i'm in the grass
walking towards the car it's it's all
gone and
yeah it was crazy but apparently i did a
good job and i
who knows what went down who knows what
went down i honestly did not remember
it the last 59 minutes and 30 seconds
but then i started
then i got i got thrown in luckily i had
alcohol at the time because i would have
been able to do it without it and i did
the cop act every
once a week for a year
and
i was doing four or five bachelorette
parties every weekend as well
i did that for about a year or two then
i'm starting my own company explicit
strippers
and to cut out the middleman i'd give
him a 75 show up fee and i would get 75
each show and i keep my tips and this is
in what city now
towards the end of orange county
um
yeah i started stripping in orange
county and right before i moved to l.a i
think i started my company
uh but then i started in orange county
but i advertised in la orange county san
diego eventually
i ended up going to hawaii and dallas as
well
i had i had the
the biggest stripping agency on the west
coast once once i got it rolling if you
googled loss even and then
when i moved to las vegas as well if you
googled las vegas
los angeles orange county
san diego hawaii strippers male
strippers female strippers any of that
i'm top one in just about all of those i
had the biggest company i had a lot of
people working for me
and i started booking go-go dancers in
in la as well i was booking the the
hollywood men at the abbey
in west hollywood
um i did a couple fetish clubs as well
big a big gay club
the abbey is yeah it's it's one of the
highest grossing
clubs in the world or it was and yeah
it's it's gay it's it's higher end
and
they contacted me because all my
strippers were straight
and
but higher end gay clubs want straight
dancers there
and so that's why they hired my company
i booked it for a few years i booked the
the the gay pride parade as well i
booked 20
20
guys in white shorts dancing around
their their gay pride float for the gay
pride it was uh it was a good time so it
was fun
it was ridiculous but it was fun
and then eventually that led to
something else right
so
okay
so when i was stripping
i was always interested in escorting you
know
up in my game taking to the next level
making more money
and i reached out to a few companies
once my confidence started developing a
little bit
even though it was still
pretty much the alcohol but i like to
think that it was developing a little
bit then your confidence doesn't develop
until you leave that behind and you
start going out there sober
but i called a few companies to inquire
about escorting and
all the escort agencies none of them had
any women clients so you'd have to see
men and
i wasn't willing to to do that most of
my dancers a lot of the the straight
guys that i knew would do that
but i never did
and
so about a year went by and cowboys for
angels contacted me
and this was the first exclusive
straight mail for a straight female
companion website ever done
he found me on model mayhem actually and
saw that i had stripping experience he
liked my look
over six foot
um
a few other things that went into that
equation
and
he went on tyra banks
and that kind of blew his company up a
little bit so he was expanding looking
for new guys he brought me on i became
one of his top guys
fairly shortly but i was still only
getting one or two bookings a month
and they were
like one in two hour bookings i don't
even remember if i got a four hour
booking at that time or not
and uh
and yeah like one or two a month i
thought it was i thought it was amazing
i thought i was you know king [ __ ]
um
it was it was it was great i felt like
you know i was at the
the top of of something on top of
something i figured something out
little did i know what it would
eventually lead to
so i worked with him for about a year
and then the tv show gigolos contacted
him and asked him for his top guy he
sent me in
i
i knew if i said i was a white rapping
gigolo i'd make this reality show no
problem and and i did
and
man the rest is history after that it
went quick we shot we shot the trailer
the sizzle reel and then two seasons in
one year next thing i know i'm moving to
vegas
my rate goes up i have a four hour
minimum at this time i'm getting 24
24-hour weekend week bookings a 10-day i
think i had some
10-day to two-week bookings too going
all over the world
south africa morocco
hawaii
europe i mean you name it i've been
there in japan
and things were going good things were
going good um where do those bookings
entail
like when a man typically hires a female
prostitute
they'll
they'll get to sex very quickly and then
it's over with sometimes in 10 15
minutes
yeah um
these aren't prostitute bookings um
that's that's what i'm saying that's
right yeah that's different
yeah that's that's illegal right even if
it was legal it's something i may have
done at one time like before the show
but it's not something that i would have
done up until recent time
i mean whenever you go on a date with
somebody you're hopeful you know you two
will connect and it'll lead to that we
all we all want to have sex you know
we're all very sexual people and it's
unfortunate you know that we don't
we aren't able to connect more with
people and and experience that more but
that's that's always the hopes when
you're when you're winning a date with
somebody who you're you know especially
someone who you're attracted to or
someone you know takes immaculate care
of themselves mentally and physically
and
so the the bookings with women that
would be you know for for hours or
weekends or even longer
would entail what kind of stuff just
just companionship
yeah i mean that's that's what we sell
nothing's guaranteed the the show the
show was a show you know we um
we had simulated scenes soft core stuff
with all the clients so you know
sometimes it was expected but whenever i
did interviews or anything you know i
put it out there and said that you know
it's it's never
a guarantee i've never sold a sexual
favor in my life
that's kind of where i'm going
the bookings yeah they're advertised as
as companionship i mean i offer so much
more now but what what what what were
they in reality
you guys would just like
have dinner together or or what was it
okay so most most the time with the
bookings
once once i started to take off i didn't
do too many short bookings anymore those
were there was a lot of requests for
those i still i still get a ton of them
for like one and two hour bookings
usually it's couples
where
the guy is opening
open to the woman experimenting with
another man or something like that
and that really never was my thing and
unfortunately that was expected you know
sometimes when i'd see couples i haven't
seen couples in a long time
anymore because it was all it was always
weird and
and that's that's not what
you know i was selling and you know you
want to make the client happy and if
there's expectations you know it's
it's unfortunate you know i'd get bad
reviews because i i wouldn't go through
with them because i'd have man i had
some
i had some some some nasty bookings i
had some
billionaire from another country try to
force me upon his wife who's saying no
and as he's saying no means yes i've
been in some some really weird and
horrible situations like i wanted to
knock this dude out i wanted to beat the
[ __ ] out of him i almost did i almost
did but he's a billionaire i'd probably
i probably won't be here talking if if i
did that she was one of the most
just you get abused in every way people
i've ever met and it was so gross he's
telling me
no means yes
all the other guys do this we've had
guys before we've had guys in new york
who who have done this i'll pay you
double
like i'm like dude get out of here what
is wrong with you like i wanted to hurt
him really bad i want to hurt him really
bad i still do
um
most of them weren't bad like that
though usually usually it's cool people
usually people are open sexually they're
they're swingers or whatever but you
know those all sound like mail driven
bookings even though there's a woman
involved it's almost like the man is
who's
sometimes sometimes for sure yeah and i
could tell
you know i have a good uh gaydar that's
that's for for sure especially after
about gaining west hollywood sometimes
guys want you to do things with their
wife while they watch i heard i've heard
that yeah yeah so but have you had
bookings where it's just a female
looking for a male companion
of course yeah that's that's the
majority of them that's what i think
yeah yeah yeah and what are those like
okay so
we're bouncing around everywhere okay
um what do you mean whether they're like
what what else what what do you want
what do women look for in a companion
so
i mean it's a little tricky with my
rates since my rates have gone up since
i've been so successful and i've done so
well you know obviously
you know they they don't want to pay not
everybody can pay my eight hour 24 hour
rate
but most you know women would want that
they want something longer
um they they do look for more of
connection i mean
i don't want to say that just women do
that want that though i i believe that
men and women both want that just
men have been conditioned and programmed
differently
to think that
what they need is just to get off real
quick and and and screw as many girls as
possible and
and
it's unfortunate
because you know deep down if anybody's
being honest with you everybody wants a
lot more than that and
if that's all you get you're you're
going to feel empty if you're getting
hurt very quickly yeah you're going to
feel empty on either side if you're the
the sex worker or
or the guy or the girl who's just trying
to get a quick fix it doesn't work like
that when you're with somebody and
you're intimate with them your energies
everything intertwines
and you you connect with them and when
you just leave that behind and there's
there's no other fulfillment on on a
mental level it's just it's such a waste
and
and yeah we're just conditioned so
poorly to believe that
you know that's that's that's what we
should desire and
you know these these we're busy working
and so one night stands are a good thing
they're they're not they're not and the
clients that i have now
um
i only see a few of them and i only see
i'll see anybody one time
but i only see people who i'm gonna see
again and i've cut out as many people as
i can
from the because i i don't want to be
with that many people because i know
what it will do to you
hmm interesting yeah i'm sure this
experience you've been doing it for
years now right
yeah like eight years now i'm sure
you've learned a lot that that you would
not have learned if you hadn't done this
kind of work
for sure i understand i understand you
know energy sexual energy
you know relationships
very well i'm uh i'm writing another
book on everything this one's going to
be
this one some some next level stuff what
what what do women want
everybody wants the same thing it's not
it's not just women
i hate that
i hate that people always you know just
just ask what do women want that's um
you know that's that's playing with some
words and creating something that's
that's not real we we all want the same
thing we all want the same thing we want
connection we don't want to we don't
want a quick fix we really don't
that's great and do you find
that the the women that you'll
that'll hire you
just have a deeper understanding of of
relationships and
this than
the majority of people the the men that
are out there i mean what are they
missing it's women too are these women
they're married it's women too man we're
still monkeys throwing our [ __ ] nobody
knows what they're doing you know
people know so little about
relationships no but nobody understands
what they want no but nobody gives
themselves enough time to you know
sit and reflect and meditate and we're
just plugged into this world we're
driven by money and we don't have time
for anything and nobody prioritizes you
know what the most important things are
and it is reflecting upon what we truly
desire and digging into our heart and
soul and sitting in silence and and
listening
and so few people do that so it's not
just the men who are lost the women who
are are lost too um
and they're coming to me man this is
this is what's really pushed me to find
some answers they're coming to me and be
like i don't i don't know what to do i
don't know are these married women or
single or both mostly single
um
usually the the married women
their husband knows and sometimes
they'll usually the husband will meet up
and give me the pick up and say hinds
they take good care of her then he'll
bounce that's that's usually what
happens with the couples
um
but one more time but so the single the
single women will
are they you think they're looking for a
you're a good looking man so they're
looking for a handsome companion
or they're just looking for a fling or
what are they looking for
answers man
i think
everybody especially now that i've you
know i've
put together a self-help book and i put
myself out there as a life and
confidence coach and healer you know
they're just they're coming for answers
so few people so few people know what
they want
yeah we're all lost aren't we
we are collectively
for sure and
you know this is what this is what's
motivated me and inspired me to to find
some answers and put my last book
together i think a lot of us are just
lonely
well i mean what's lonely
i think uh not connecting with anyone
and just
well lonely is lonely is a choice and
and the problem
the problem with being lonely is
if you don't spend enough time being
alone you will forever be lonely because
you won't find the answers that that
will take you to to a place to be able
to connect with people and know what you
do desire and want
and
i mean i'm on my side right here i have
life can be lonely but we are not alone
and i've played with those
i played with those words a lot to to
dig into what loneliness really is and
it's it's it's not it's not being alone
like you got to be alone like you got to
be happy alone you got to love yourself
you got to do these things to have the
chances of meeting someone else who's
developed and put that work in too i
always say with relationships
you know it's people who haven't put the
work in meeting people who haven't put
the work in that never works and people
who have put the work in with people who
haven't put the work in that never works
either you need two people who have put
that work in if you're going to connect
and have something special and not be
lonely find somebody you know to to
explore life with and
the percentage of people who have you
know put it put enough time into to
figure some things out
like it's low it's like yeah
it's
say less than one percent of one percent
i really do it's so low and and most of
people out there who think they have
something figured out they don't
they they really don't they're not
they're not teaching anything you know
they're still depressed i see through it
all i see through it all
i see that that fear and
and that not knowing and thinking
they're gonna die alone and this all
these burdens and and and
unnecessary worries that that plague
their mind that don't allow them to
evolve and become one of these people
you gotta let go of all those fears and
worries to get anywhere in life
it takes a lot of courage and
perseverance and for sure it takes it
takes that guidance to find the courage
you know we don't just have courage
we we have to i never had courage when i
was a kid
you know i i found some lucky guidance
somewhere and then then you find that
lucky guidance to drive you to to seek
more
your hunger to learn which you mentioned
earlier
i think is key to
well that's guidance though that's
guidance though you know i'm a firm
believer i know for sure that we all
have the same brain we're all born with
the same brain we're a product of our
environment we're experiences so we have
to have that guidance we have to have it
you know
we we could go way down that hole if if
you want but now i'm a firm believer
that we have the same brain we all have
the same capabilities and we all just
need that right motivation drive push
guidance to to push us to
to go the right direction
i don't believe some people have more
courage than others i believe some
people have had better guidance to
that someone gave them let
gotten in their brain and
taught them that they can be courageous
you need you need that you're not just
born being courageous you need someone
telling you oh you had role models that
kind of showed you that sure
that's a big part of it too yeah i see a
lot of people that just didn't have any
worthwhile role models in their lives i
was one of them for for many many years
but on one hand they
inspired me in other ways i guess you
could say and then you learn to be your
own like
guide
that should be the goal that should be
the goal i i feel like we need some
lucky guidance to to get on a certain
track then after that and then you know
we can explore the the free will
argument if you want as well i like to
think that if we
operate our full potential
that we do have the possibility of
establishing and experiencing free will
so you know we we become
you know creators and and we decide how
capable and confident and courageous we
are
how often are your back to your
your gigolo experiences how often are
those
just
the the flip like the female version of
a typical male prostitute
where it's just sex and that's it
well never with me
um
that's what's been
wanted and expected at times and
i i would get in a tricky situation
there because
it's not what's offered it's not what's
sold but then it's kind of expected and
number one i don't wanna i don't wanna
hurt anybody by not going through with
this and then they're thinking i can't
even pay for this
you know so i try to explain to them i
would explain to them from the beginning
you know i i only i'm only with people
who i can i can connect and communicate
with
and even on the show when i'd simulate
the the scenes on on the tv show
just about every person i simulated the
scene with would order a hawk talk off
my website i sell those they started as
confidence coaching and life coaching i
always call them hawk talks and i do
them like once a month or twice a month
and uh they'd order one and every single
just about every single person would
hawk talk me and start crying why didn't
you sleep with me you slept with
everybody else on the show i'm like no i
didn't i'm an amazing actor you're not
going to see my penis going into one
vagina i promise
they don't even they don't show any of
that like how i'm a good actor even the
teddy bear scene like all of them like
they're simulated so
there was there was a couple times you
know where i'm like i'm gonna destroy
this person if if i don't sleep with
them
because they're gonna think i can't even
pay for sex even though that's not
what's being offered so there's a couple
times earlier in my career where i did
go through where i didn't want to
because there wasn't the communication
and connection there
um but then when i would do that it
would it would destroy me like it like
it insulted my soul i felt like i was
really doing something wrong
that was early on that was many years
ago but
it's still like
is this something i i i i could never do
because i how does how does someone who
has
that you know is in touch with their
soul and has this deeper understanding
of all these things end up with with a
career like that
i don't know because i've i've always
been this this seeker of this the the
truth
no i mean go to my social media and
you'll see you know i don't hold
anything back i tell you how it is and
you know i don't get bullied i don't i
don't get pressured into
you know saying things i don't feel and
i've really become this
this person who can't live i mean one of
the kicks in my book is you know don't
lie it's it's one of the biggest things
you have to do to to evolve and and be
able to get in touch with these things
and evolve and listen to your soul you
can't lie you got to stop lying about
everything and i felt like
you know sleeping with with people i
didn't connect and communicate with on a
great level even
you know it's it's a lie and you're
insulting yourself and you're doing
something you shouldn't be doing yeah i
agree 100
it's very interesting so where do you
see your future going do you see your
self continuing with this or getting out
of it
i've been getting out
um i've been seeing less and less
clients
you know i had
i had the agency's two biggest months
back to back i made 80 grand one month
and 70 grand the next
and
that's when i'm like what if what am i
doing i'm just i'm just wore out i'm
depleted what does it do to your
personal relationships what personal
relationships
that's that's what i expect
um pretty hard to have those yeah in the
in the when i was you know taking
when the show kicked off and i was
taking as many bookings as i could
you know making much money as possible
and buying as many houses as possible i
invested it wise i didn't blow it at all
luckily because now i can do whatever i
want but um
no i wore myself out but i've been
backing off for years now and i've been
i've always said you know i'll always do
it as long as
i have the right clients you know
they're healthy for me and i'm healthy
for them so i'll always be open to it
but i am taking i am going a new
direction now
um
and i'm gonna a lot of people
a lot of people want to book me without
that
without that that possibility of that
you know closeness and connection and
long bookings and overnight and weekend
bookings a lot of people want to book me
without that but right now i do i do a
i'll do a one four hour meet and greet
but after that it's an eight hour
minimum
are you are you in some way addicted to
this kind of work no no not at all and
and i mean my my prices are are high
right now
because
it does entail the companionship and
getting in and getting close to somebody
and you can't do that with a lot of
people but i do want to i want to see
more people in in other ways without
those expectations at all i actually
i recently purchased some land in sedona
and i'm building a healing sanctuary
there
and i'm gonna i'm gonna continue to do
i'm gonna do a half day in full day
bookings where i take people
i i'm off-roading on a razor guided
tours around sedona spirit quest hikes
uh meditations uh coaching crystal
hunting
grand canyon tours
uh airport pickup and i'm gonna have a
few places for them to stay on my
property as well so i'm gonna be
offering that i will still continue to
offer
uh offer the mail companion bookings but
like i said it's it's got to be the
right people they have to be healthy for
me i need to be healthy for them and
there has to be connection and and
communication there
it's a very interesting life you've
carved out for yourself
yeah
it is i mean i had no idea what it was
especially for a madison wisconsin boy
yeah i had no idea what i was getting
into in the beginning of it and
i didn't understand you know most people
struggled like i once did as well and
after i put myself out there hustler
magazine did a
interview and labeled me confidence man
and
after that people started coming to me
for confidence advice
and i mean because you explained how
like you had no very little confidence
yeah and now you seem very confident i i
did i i did have it that was you know
in the middle of shooting the the
gigolos tv show that's when my
confidence really developed i i got away
from alcohol
and i could get in front of the cameras
and go on dates and talk to girls
without alcohol and then but people
started asking me about it and once
again it was
you know okay now i know how to be
confident but now how do i teach it so
they inspired me to dig into that that
that really you know what what what were
the keys for you to gain confidence
more than anything
more than anything with confidence
you need to
develop your intuition with other people
you need to start reading them you need
to start seeing through the show that
most people put on
when you start seeing that no very few
people are confident
most people it's a show then you then
you start realizing that okay
okay
if it's a show with most people then
maybe i have a chance at this then you
start putting yourself out there and
when you really start understanding how
similar we are and that we have the same
brains and the same capabilities you
have to understand that and then you got
to go for it obviously you know
everybody will tell you that you got to
put yourself out there and you got to go
for it yeah what would you say is the
most important thing you've learned in
your life
probably about energy
i think energy is something that most
people take for granted it's becoming a
little more mainstream now
people are starting to understand you
know we're we're waking up
but you have to charge most people spend
most of their time
depleting and being encompassed with
dating as many people as possible to
find their soulmate making as much money
as possible so they can have the nicest
cars possible and
and it's this it's it's all nonsense
you need to
you need to understand the importance of
of sitting in silence and charging
and that's the only way it's going to
allow you to
speak through your soul and be a
be evolved human
very interesting
all right nick well thank you so much
for sharing your story
thank you i wish you the best of luck
thanks thank you
you